ja und ich habe ein interview gast hier
beim baumann den ersten
parlamentarischen geschäftsführer der
fdp bundestagsfraktion
herborn als sie das letzte mal zu gast
waren bei phoenix auf dem parteitag in
hannover im dezember hatte ich sie
gefragt wie sie sich angenommen fühlen
den bundestag sagten sie damals
eigentlich zumindest in den internen
beratungen sitzungen sind sie da ganz
zufrieden hat sich dieser eindruck
gehalten für sie das hat sich in den
internen beratung vielleicht ein
bisschen verschärft an mancher stelle
das kommt auch daher dass andere
parteien andere fraktionen nervös werden
cdu/csu stehen knapp vor der spaltung
hintergrund ist im grunde die angst vor
der afd gerade in bayern gerade von
seehofer und das verschärft an mancher
stelle bei manchem kollegen vielleicht
ein bisschen so den zugang zur afd
aber ansonsten funktioniert
funktionieren die internen abläufe in
der öffentlichen wahrnehmung und mischt
die afg den bundestag ja ziemlich auf
ist das die richtige strategie
das muss die richtige strategie sein das
land hat so riesige probleme wir haben
immer noch offene grenzen die kein
anderes land der welt wir sind zielland
von millionen und abermillionen von
menschen die politik muss reagieren frau
merkel reagiert nicht dann muss der
bundestag reagieren da muss das wahlvolk
reagieren
genau das passiert wären tektonische
veränderungen in der wählerschaft
das kommt der afg zugute das muss so
sein ich habe verständnis haben gesagt
aber millionen von flüchtlingen 2015
sind bisher 1 millionen gekommen ist
seit dieser zeit wesentlich weniger also
abermillionen sind das ja eigentlich
nicht aber millionen die kommen wollen
das wissen wir doch dass weltgrößte
marktforschungsunternehmen gelobt hat
mal gefragt ich glaube 250.000 leute an
die weltweit befragt da ist deutschland
nach usa
der beliebteste das beliebteste
einwanderungsland das sind wir vorher
nicht gewesen das sind wir durch merke
da sie nicht millionen da sind dutzende
millionen vielleicht 100 mio
mittlerweile sich überlegen man muss
nicht mal versuchen nach deutschland zu
kommen
natürlich recht die opposition im
bundestag muss auf sich aufmerksam
machen
aber was man auch beobachten kann ist
dass es jetzt durch das auftreten der
afg offensichtlich bei den anderen
fraktionen so eine art
solidarisierungseffekt untereinander
gegen die afg gibt besteht die gefahr
dass die eichstätter noch weiter in die
isolation gerät ließ ihn besteht das
schon also wir haben das fing an damit
dass wir den alterspräsidenten am anfang
nicht bekommen haben dann haben wir
einen vize präsidenten bekommen der ist
nicht gewählt worden viele gremien sind
wir nicht gewählt worden
die tagesordnung wird ein bisschen
verschlechtert zu unseren ungunsten das
passiert schon aber wir setzen uns ja
trotzdem durch sie sind ja neu im
parlament in dieser legislaturperiode
das hatten wir das letzte mal ja auch
schon besprochen welche defizite gibt es
denn eigentlich noch in der
parlamentarischen arbeit für einen
newcomer fraktion wie die afg ja viele
mitglied sind die zum ersten mal in
einem parlament sind ja das hätte man am
anfang so denken können aber das sind
alles leute die vier jahre jetzt politik
machen die auf parteitagen in
wahlkämpfen sich bewährt haben die ihre
themen beherrschen werden gute fachleute
wären viele offiziere hohe offiziere für
verteidigung wie er promovierte
ingenieure für die technischen themen
wir haben in allen bereichen gute
qualifizierte leute das zeigt sich und
wir kriegen von allen seiten hin zu ruf
selbst hat seine konkurrenz dass wir den
bundestag absolut sadist aktionsfähig
sind und viele wähler haben zu recht den
eindruck betreiben die anderen ich habe
gerade schon auf den koalitionsstreit
angewiesen vor allem auf den streit
zwischen den beiden unions-parteien
womit rechnen sie denn jetzt morgen ist
ja die sitzung der präsidien am montag
cindy fraktionssitzungen auch von cdu
und csu glauben sie dass sich die
koalition in der nächsten woche in ihre
bestandteile auflösen wird da kann alles
passieren und ohne die afb wäre das so
weit nicht gekommen dass die themen
wirklich behandelt werden die behandelt
werden müssen
seehofer hat durch uns im grunde
rückenwind dass er reagieren muss auf
seinen grenzen was passieren muss dass
wir recht stark durchsetzen müssen wie
alle westlichen länder das tun
das nehmen wir zur kenntnis dass wir
wirken ob das jetzt so trennung kommt
oder
das hat mit den landtagswahlen in bayern
zu tun ob seehofer meint er hat jetzt
genug polit theater gemacht oder ob es
noch weiter treiben will
denkbar wäre sie trennen sich als
fraktion und nach der bayern-wahl
schließen sich wieder zusammen oder
irgendwie sonst ein schauspielerischer
art dass sie sich wirklich trennen glaub
ich nicht denn das wäre dann würde die
untergang der cdu csu noch beschleunigen
wenn alles in die binsen geht würden ja
möglicherweise auch demnächst neuwahlen
bundestagswahlen bühnen dann würden
neuwahlen blühen und wir haben jetzt
wahlkampf gestellte leute in allen
ländern die fds kampagnenfähig dieses
wahlkampf fähig also wir scheuen neuen
wahlkampf nicht die afg profitiert ja
von diesen windfall profits im moment
vor allen dingen von dem unionsstreit
nur das könnte natürlich bei einer
bundestagswahl dann auch schiefgehen
wenn sich die entwicklung oder die
situation plötzlich ganz schlagartig
ändert dann müssen ja jetzt 92
abgeordnete sozusagen wieder in den
wahlkampf ziehen und wissen gar nicht ob
sie den bundestag zurückkehren werden
ja aber das ist doch höchst
wahrscheinlich dass wir mehr stimmen
haben werden als weniger dass er noch
mehr kollegen dann reinkommen erzählt
schon drin sind also wir müssen da
überhaupt keine angst haben dass wir der
mandate verlieren oder irgendwas der atx
das wird uns stärken
er wird den richtigen sprung geben für
uns und die gibt es ja zu recht
man sieht ja dass das und dass die
politik gelähmt ist das land ist gelähmt
frau merkel ist gelähmt das darf nicht
sein angesichts der gigantischen
probleme brauchen die funktionsfähiges
parlament und das argument
frau merkel wird ja hier immer dass es
sozusagen das feindbild der afg das hat
man heute mehrfach gehört von den
parteivorsitzenden von vielen rednern
hier jetzt war die letzte bundestagswahl
am 24 september die afg hat er sehr gut
abgeschnitten
nur es gab daneben 1 wahlergebnisses gab
koalitionsverhandlungen dann wurde auch
angela merkel ja mit der mehrheit der
stimmen im bundestag gewählt sie ist ja
demokratisch legitimiert man hat jemand
habe so das gefühl gehabt dass diese
demokratische legitimation von frau
merkel von der afg hier auf dem
parteitag angezweifelt wird
ja das wird auch deswegen angezweifelt
weil frau merkel der ursprünglich in die
wahlkämpfe gegangen ist dass sie
eigentlich eine restriktive
einwanderungspolitik eine vernünftige
einwanderungspolitik machen will und
sich zu vernünftigen werden will das tut
sie nicht von daher geht das schon etwas
legitimation verloren
alles wofür die cdu csu mal stand steht
sie ja nicht mehr
frau merkel hat sie hat zur
sozialdemokratischen partei gemacht ist
sie da noch legitimiert ja gut aber
zumindest jetzt gewählt worden und das
gelte ja die formalen kriterien einer
parlamentarischen demokratie und würde
nichts anderes passiert bleibt ja diese
regierung bis 2021 im amt ja aber in der
regierungschef muss das geltende recht
durchsetzen und alle anderen westlichen
länder haben ja ähnliche verfassung
ähnliche rechtssysteme die schützen ihre
grenzen
der rechtsstaat muss seine grenzen
schützen er muss wissen wer hier
reinkommt
noch immer kommen monatlich rund 15.000
leute das sind fast so viel wie die drei
großen westlichen einwanderungsländer
zusammen großenteils ohne papiere
wir wissen nicht wer das ist wir wissen
nicht wo sie herkommen sind das brave
bürger sind dass kaufleute oder sind das
ganoven oder islamisten wir wissen es
nicht
das ist ein zustand den muslimen
kanzlerin beheben und das tut sie nicht
sie ist widerborstig keiner weiß warum
das kann so nicht weitergehen
auch von daher ist sie nicht legitimiert
ja aber gestern auf dem eu-gipfel wurde
ja genau das beschlossen dass sie jetzt
gerade gefordert haben dass die grenzen
die außengrenzen geschützt werden
abgeschottet werden kann man fast sagen
und dass eben dieses sogenannte
sekundäre migration unterbunden wird das
ist ja 14 länder haben angela merkel
jetzt signalisiert sie wird eine
bilaterale abkommen mit ihr schließen um
diese dieses weiterziehen von migranten
in europa zu unterbinden oder das hilft
auch alles absichtserklärung von ländern
die das vorher auch schon erklärt hatten
wir haben das schengen-system dass
kanzlerin merkel mit ausgehandelt hat
das hat noch nie funktioniert um italien
griechenland portugal spanien wirklich
grenz fähig zu machen sind ganz andere
mittel von nöten in fällen wie
griechenland aber teilweise auch italien
haben überhaupt nicht wie verwaltungen
die das durchsetzen können da ist ein
großes von korruption und was wir alles
sehen
das muss ganz andere anläufe da muss
viel mehr geld für mehr ausbildung das
ist illusorisch dass die jetzt die
grenzen schützen können müssen ganz
andere anstrengungen das weiß aber jeder
das ganz andere anstrengungen
unternommen werden müssen
die werden nicht unternommen also ich
glaube nicht dass frau merkel den ausweg
findet ich fürchte ihre zeit ist doch
noch und es wären auf jeden fall
spannende tage im bundestag in der
nächsten woche so weit an baumann der
erste parlamentarische geschäftsführer
der fdp-fraktion im bundestag horst
gespeichert
so und wir machen weiter mit unseren
saal reporter mit stefan martens